[Music]
on this monday night making it easier
for the fully vaxxed to come back
what the new rules allow canadian
travelers with two doses to do
it is the traveler's responsibility to
plan ahead the app you'll need to use
and the demands for a more comprehensive
plan for travelers
mixing mrna vaccines with fizer
shipments delayed
should you take moderna as your second
shot it's like just going to the gas
station you know you don't care about
the brand
plus taking the cheer out of the
olympics new restrictions so the tokyo
games can go on
and a new manitoba writers story of
indigenous traditions
becomes a new york times bestseller
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with breaking news tonight a
tornado has touched down in quebec in a
community
just north of montreal
environment canada confirmed the tornado
touched down
based on video shared online it happened
in
mascoch a community about 45 kilometers
north of montreal
municipal officials confirm one person
is dead there are reports of widespread
damage
the local chapter of the red cross has
been deployed to the area to assist
between 50 to 100 people
who have been displaced the town's mayor
is urging people to stay away from the
affected areas so emergency crews can go
in and help those who need it and clear
debris
there is a severe thunderstorm watch in
place for parts of southern quebec but
there was no specific tornado warning
from environment canada there is another
small step coming towards a return to
normal life at least when it comes to
travel for canadians
starting on july 5th most international
travel restrictions for canadians
permanent residents and
certain foreign nationals who are fully
vaccinated will
lift they'll no longer have to
self-isolate or stay
in a quarantine hotel on arrival in
canada they must have had vaccines
approved for use in canada
children under 12 who are not vaccinated
will be able to travel too but will
still have to quarantine
at home for two weeks as of today more
than seven million canadians have had
that double dose just under 20 percent
of the population
this cracks open the door to easier
travel but it's not a complete restart
plan
and it doesn't open up canada to fully
vaccinated citizens from other countries
and our top story tonight david aiken
explains the new rules and what you need
to know to prove
your vaccination status we haven't
reached the finish line there's a lot
more work to do
an important point for fully vaccinated
canadians and permanent residents
who can start thinking about punching
their tickets and avoiding
quarantine but there is a catch to be
very clear
with fully vaccinated travelers you will
still need to meet a series of
requirements
requirement 1 you must use the federal
government's
arrive can app on your smartphone that
app is mandatory
and has already been used two million
times our arrive can app has proven to
be a very effective application
using that app enter your travel history
for the prior 14 days
enter confirmation of a negative pcr
test taken
before you return to canada then upload
digital copies of your proof of
vaccination
and right now the only vaccines canada
will accept
are pfizer moderna astrazeneca and
johnson and johnson
no others it is the traveler's
responsibility to plan ahead
to understand their obligations and to
ensure that they are eligible
you will also have to carry a paper copy
of your vaccine proof
upon arrival in canada you must take
another pcr test
do all that and if your tests are
negative your reward
is at hand fully vaccinated travelers
will no longer have to quarantine or
complete the eight day test now for
everyone else there are
no changes to the rules the government's
quarantined hotels will still be running
and foreign nationals on non-essential
travel in other words
tourists are still prohibited this
government believes that a prudent
uh careful and cautious approach to
alleviating measures is what's required
and there wasn't even a hint today of
what comes next when will we move to
the next set of restrictions coming off
in fact industry and travel groups
condemn the federal government
for not even providing benchmarks or
metrics that must be met
to move to the next phase of border
reopening donna
all right david thanks it will still be
a challenge to navigate all the rules
around travel not just for canadians
coming home but
for those trying to make plans for trips
to other countries in the months ahead
from tourists itching to fly to families
anxious to reunite
obstacles remain in place robin gill
explains angela joy and her family are
anxious to visit the united states she's
fully vaccinated
but her two children both under 12 are
not i would feel comfortable traveling
right now but it's really just the
logistical
afterwards that is kind of a hiccup in
the whole thing
any travel outside of canada would
require a 14-day quarantine coming back
for the young ones even though under the
new rules mom doesn't have to
we want to be able to travel like
everybody else in like the rest of the
world
the ontario family would like to reunite
with angela's dad mike at their cabin in
washington state
he's double dosed and stuck in british
columbia just a 45 minute drive to the
family's second home at the base of
mount baker
which he can even see from this side of
the border but can't get to
what's the sense of having a second
vaccination if you can't move around
freely
undoubtedly this will be challenging for
families who want to travel
travel agents say there is still some
hesitancy but that travel demand is
picking up
we are seeing what i would call a bit of
a booking boom
nowhere near the levels pre-pandemic
there's really pent
up demand we've been locked up locked
down
for so long you can only look at this
same four walls for so long
for now mike joy can only stare at
family photos and feel frustrated
that it could be easier for him to fly
to europe than to drive across the
border
nhl players can move freely across the
border now but yet
they for some reason
choose to neglect the the average person
and here's the other need for travel in
the joy family
angela's husband is a pilot and hasn't
been working since the pandemic began
i want people traveling not just for
myself but so my husband can go back to
work
just another reason they're so ready to
finally
take off robin gill global news
vancouver
further easing of restrictions will
require more canadians to get fully
vaccinated and on that front more
progress is expected this week
over 5 million more doses are slated for
delivery to canada
that includes nearly 2.8 million doses
from moderna and
2.4 million from pfizer bayentech this
week's visor delivery though has been
delayed by a few days and that's caused
some clinics which were counting on it
to pivot to moderna public health
experts say because both
are mrna vaccines they are
interchangeable
but there are reports some people are
canceling appointments to wait for
pfizer
as jamie morocco reports public health
officials urged canadians to take the
first vaccine
they're offered ottawa residents rolled
up their sleeve to receive a shot of
modernist covet 19 vaccine regardless of
what their first dose was
we are being told that either one is
good
so we'll we'll do it but not everyone
was so at ease with the idea of mixing
doses
neither one as long as it's too the same
i haven't seen the science that says you
can mix
after a delay in canada's pfizer
shipment ontario announced
this week it was reserving the vaccine
for young people between 12 and 17.
the only shot approved for that age
group quebec is also offering only
moderna at its walk-in clinics
meantime alberta health services says
booking with moderna will get you an
earlier appointment
you have these two different choices and
it doesn't really matter this is like
just going to the gas station you know
you don't care about the brand
well some question the lack of studies
specifically examining the mixing of
mrna vaccines
experts suggest they do appear to be
interchangeable
much like other vaccines we already use
to fight things like the seasonal flu
canada's national advisory committee on
immunization says the same goes
for moderna and pfizer you can be a
purist and say look the trials have been
done that way but right now we have so
much real world evidence developing
doctors say getting different shots of
the cova 19 vaccine can even increase
the likelihood you'll be protected from
variants
thanks to a wider range of antibodies
ramping up your immune response
good news as the aggressive delta strain
threatens a fourth wave
in a hot spot in toronto daniella
digessep antonio
is relieved her parents were able to get
fully vaccinated with the mixed dose i'm
just glad they did so now we can feel a
little bit safer
and they can go out a little bit more
safer and sooner too
jamie rocker global news toronto
one of the wild cards in reopening plans
is that highly transmissible delta
variant which is fast becoming the
dominant strain around the world
canada's public health agency says it's
been detected now in every province and
at least one territory
as of late last week more than 2 000
cases had been confirmed in canada
though whole genome
sequencing is needed to be sure of the
actual numbers
in the united kingdom the delta variant
is responsible for a steep rise in cases
and experts are watching the situation
closely
eric sorenson explains what's been
discovered so far
remember these symptoms headaches runny
noses
sore throats they're making a comeback
as common symptoms of kovid
as vaccines provide better protection
especially in older populations who've
doubled their
doses more quickly the spread of the
delta variant is affecting more young
people
and in a different way according to
british researchers it's more like
a bad cold in this younger population
and people don't realize that the number
one symptom is headache
saw and then followed by sore throat
runny nose
and fever reported coveted symptoms of
headaches sore throats and runny noses
are much more common in people under age
40 than those over 40.
original covid symptoms coughs and the
loss of smell and taste
are less frequent now still the delta
variant is twice as transmissible as the
original virus
and young people are stoking the spread
they still go out to parties and they
might spread around to six other people
we think this is fueling a lot of the
problem after the uk reopened last month
case numbers per capita have risen
in canada the case numbers are still
coming down but are being watched
closely as this country opens up
even if the delta variant spreads
quickly some doctors say two doses of
vaccines
will offer protection from serious
illness now that the majority of people
are having just basically
you know the sniffles we don't need to
monitor that the primary metric for us
is hospitalization because that is what
led us to have to
restrict the community now if you have a
bunch of cases and no hospitalizations
or very few
we don't need to lock down anymore there
are two time lags that make it hard to
predict the near future in canada
public contact is just starting up and
second doses are still catching up
gauging the spread of the variant and
the strength of the shield against it
will require time
but doctors are increasingly confident
that a future surge will not overwhelm
hospitals
if we keep vaccinating it's important
for us to not have confidence
in how effective these vaccines are and
they are our ticket out of here we're on
the off ramp right now
with enough second doses an off-ramp
with more cases in bed at home
and fewer in the intensive care unit
eric sorensen global news
toronto for the first time in more than
a century a private citizen has received
a formal rebuke
from the house of commons opposition mps
say it was necessary after the head of
canada's public health agency ian
stewart
refused to hand over documents related
to two scientists originally from china
who were fired from the national
microbiology lab in winnipeg
in 2019 to reprimand you
for the public health agency of canada's
contempt
refusing to submit the required
documents
the house further ordered you to
immediately submit unredacted version
of the documents to it earlier this year
a house of commons committee ordered the
public health agency to turn over
unredacted documents on the decision to
fire the scientists
that did not happen last week mps passed
a conservative-backed motion to find the
health agency in contempt of parliament
the government has said it cannot turn
over the documents because what it calls
national security concerns
no charges have been laid in the case
but the two scientists remain under rcmp
investigation
tracking claudette coming up the
tropical storm moving up the atlantic
coast heading
for canada plus two catholic churches go
up in flames
in bc
a powerful storm is tracking north
toward canada right now after leaving a
trail of destruction
in the southern u.s tropical storm
claudette's being blamed for more than a
dozen deaths
in alabama it caused dangerous flash
flooding and spawned a powerful tornado
all of a sudden the trees over this way
behind the houses over there they just
kind of just
it was just like they imploded
claudette is expected to lose some steam
as it enters canadian waters though
forecasters warn it could still bring
heavy downpours and gusty winds to parts
of nova scotia
and newfoundland and labrador tomorrow
no storm surge
is expected in british columbia an
investigation is underway after two
catholic churches were destroyed in
overnight fires
the churches were located about 40
kilometers apart on penticton and
soyuz indian banned lands officials say
both of the fires began about the same
time early this morning
they've not said whether they believe
the two are connected though police say
they are treating both fires as
suspicious ahead why there's going to be
an
awkward silence in the stands at the
olympics in tokyo
the summer olympics have already been
delayed by a year
spectators from foreign countries have
been told they're not welcome
but today the organizers said some
japanese spectators will be allowed
though
they won't be able to cheer redmond
shannon reports on the ever-evolving
rules around the tokyo olympics
the covet modified olympic village is
ready for athletes
and organizers say they are ready for
fans
venues will now be allowed a spectator
capacity of 50
up to a maximum of 10 000 people well i
gotta tell you my reaction this morning
when i heard that was
yay like um and and i have to do it
quietly because it's pretty much what
i'm gonna have to do when i'm in tokyo
that's because team canada's chef de
mission marnie mcbean
and everyone else at the arenas will not
be allowed
to cheer i think to golf i think to
tennis
i think to live theater that a quiet
audience can give incredible gravitas to
a moment
and for sure you know what people are
gonna still do they're gonna gasp
and they're gonna clap and they're gonna
stop the three-time olympic champion
says her athletes are just
happy to be competing after the one-year
delay
even if no canadian fans will be allowed
to travel
i know it's it's not perfect nothing has
been
over the last 18 months but there will
be witnesses there will be people
present to share in the energy in the
moment
the ioc says not everyone in the olympic
bubble
will be vaccinated for the residents of
the olympic villages it will be
well above 80 percent so far only
one in six japanese people have received
a vaccine dose
and japanese prime minister yoshihide
suga warns that if infections in the
country rise again
events may yet happen without any fans
polls suggest most japanese people want
the games postponed
or cancelled redmond shannon global news
london
a weightlifter from new zealand will
make history as the first transgender
athlete to compete
at an olympic games
that's laurel hubbard she will compete
in the women's super heavyweight 87
kilogram plus category
the 43 year old had participated in
men's weightlifting competitions before
transitioning
in 2013. in 2015 the international
olympic committee updated qualifying
requirements for transgender athletes
the rules allow women to compete as long
as their testosterone levels
meet requirements we do know that there
are many questions about fairness of
transgender athletes competing
in the olympic games but i would like to
take this opportunity to remind us all
that
morale has met all of the required
criteria
she is a very dedicated and resilient
athlete
up next an indigenous writer's words of
wisdom become
a best-seller
[Music]
an indigenous writer from winnipeg has
landed a major literary accolade
her book is called i sang you down from
the stars it tells the story of a cree
mother preparing for the birth of her
child
in late april it debuted at number three
on the new york times
best sellers list here's tasha spillet
sumner talking about her book
and what inspired her to write it ice
began to melt we visited the river i've
always admired picture books but
now with my with my daughters as a new
inspiration to write
own voice picture books in which our
children can see themselves and our
families and community
communities reflected in beautiful
dignified ways on the
page i started writing i sing you down
from the stars when i first found out i
was pregnant with isabella
i wanted to tell the story that our
teachings hold about how
children come to our families so the
story and nice singing down from the
stars is
a really a love song between a mother
and a child
in that time when she's hoping and
wishing for the child and then preparing
for the child to come
into her family's lives as an author i
feel like it's my responsibility and
part of my gift to write into reality
a world that is worthy of my daughter
that is worthy of all of our children
and each of us do that in our own way i
picked up a small stone for you
indigenous people come from such
beautiful strong teachings that have
kept our nation strong and alive through
you know some of the most horrific
things and of course we know that
nationally indigenous communities are
grieving from the
um from the revealing of so many
unmarked children
graves and so i think about particularly
now
as we hold our children in our arms it's
so important that we do everything that
we can
to ensure that they still have a
connection to that ancestral beauties
through strength to keep to keep our
nations going to keep our families
structures going
tasha spill it sumner and that is global
national for this monday i'm donna
friesen we leave you tonight with a
long-awaited change to a park
in halifax
local officials and migma leaders
gathered to unveil the peace and
friendship
park the park had originally been named
after the founder of halifax
edward cordon wallace who placed
bounties on mgmaw
men women and children the mayor says
the new name symbolizes the desire to
work together to recognize a wrong and
not be
bound by history but rather informed by
its lessons
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye
you